[Musik]
das österreichische bundesheer entsendet
soldatinnen und soldaten nach afrika
genauer gesagt nach mali zu
trainingsmission der eu es geht ja meine
trainings ausbildung vor ort auch für
die dortigen sicherheitsstrukturen die
notwendig sind und das ist natürlich
auch im sinne einer prävention natürlich
auch gedacht es geht um den kampf gegen
die organisierte kriminalität gegen
schlepper unwesen aber auch härter habe
es geht darum vor ort auch perspektiven
zu schaffen und das tun wir ja auch in
vielen bereichen auch abseits dieser
einsatz das in der entwicklungshilfe in
den sechs monaten wird ein österreicher
das kommando über die eu
trainingsmission in mali übernehmen
brigadier christian habersatter fährt
zuversichtlich nach afrika als eine der
wesentlichen herausforderungen im mal
ist die entwicklung der sicherheitslage
wie sie das wahrscheinlich auch verfolgt
haben hat sich die nicht verbessert im
gegenteil sogar etwas verschlechtert und
der wesentliche faktor ist natürlich wie
kann man die weiteren aufträge erfüllen
wie es sich anfühlt ein halbes jahr lang
familie und heimatland für einen
auslandseinsatz zu verlassen weiß
verteidigungsminister mario köpers als
meiner freut man sich noch der
einsatzvorbereitung dann auch endlich in
den einsatz zu gehen
auch die herausforderung macht natürlich
spaß auf der anderen seite ist immer
auch wehmut mit dabei man verlässt die
familie mann verlässt die heimat
man sieht sie länger nicht also das
heißt eine mischung aus gefühlslagen
aber insgesamt bin ich davon überzeugt
überwiegt die freude